madame la directrice des oeuvres de
bienfaisance et de charité du xviie
arrondissement responsable départemental
du foyer saint joseph pour la confection
des coussins aux crochets et des
corbeilles au raphia membres
actionnaires de la chorale chantons le
champ de ploërmel en gâtinais et sous
secrétaire de la commission eau des deux
gardes mobiles déchu mais gablé
d'abattre aunès élus de l'armée du salut
hasbro bénévolement la permanence pour
la distribution des soupes en sachant
mademoiselle la déléguée divisionnaire
responsable des plaies du placard bleus
et mesdames les adhérentes de notre
association nous sommes si heureuses de
vous accueillir pour cette réunion du
deuxième prime d'espoir concernant
robbie dixon activités tout cas bon pour
la réparation de l'alternance du 19 mai
vous vous répartirez au bout premier
sous le patronage de mademoiselle un
matin confection haut de guirlandes et
de fleurs en papier crépon pour la
décoration de la salle paroissiale et
animations musicales de la kermesse avec
pick up et disques microsillons
les 6èmes groupe animé par madame gros
vignal organisation des stands et petit
jeu mais chalali course en sac à main
concours de belote et jeux de jeter trop
gros cochon mais je la mets roumanie
troisième roue avec mr marie des petits
pieds de la vierge et supervisera la
bête et la vente de brioches pape au
chocolat roudoudou des t-shirts à
l'effigié de mère teresa en solex
je rappelle aux gars du club du
troisième âge qui participent au pub
numéro de danse que si tata pourrait lui
laisser hier des tutus s'il vous plaît
by km science nous savons que la
perspective de cette petite fête pouvait
frétiller d'impatience mais nous avons
encore d'autres questions à soupe mais
cette année le pèlerinage de chartres
aura lieu à orléans à cause des travaux
de ravalement de la cathédrale alors
nous partirons avec le fils de madame
truffy champ qui va donner un concert
punk à la mjc au profit des orphelins du
3ème régiment d'infanterie de verdun à
notre arrivée à 11h30
l'évêque de 10 cas serait dé michel à
12h prince pique nique devant les
lavabos municipaux à 14h ballot prison
contre les petites soeurs des pauvres et
à 16h messe où nous chanterons la
version rock de tuer mon berger au
seigneur avec mademoiselle durant à la
cornemuse et madame radicaux au taillan
nous signalons que mardi prochain
murray des repères serpente viendra nous
parler de l'organisme international dont
il s'occupe
le sida so far
sauvetage déshabiller sur rance à
l'humour oui il terminera par une
conférence intitulée de l'est fluor de
la peep et rasin sur les j'agis beat &
gamble pour les soirs de pleine lune et
pour venir à nos activités afin de
procurer des vêtements aux malheureux
nous avons décidé de fermer collecte de
stylos puisque le stylo ali
j'étais toute petite plaisanterie de mon
cru afin de divertir l'atmosphère au pad
réunion pillés et aussi pour venir en
aide à ceux qui enfin nous ferons une
collecte eux dépeint bien puisque les
épingles nourrissent pas
ni nous de nous maintenant terminer
cette réunion par le signal de
ralliement de notre association
allongée tout ensemble youpi douche avec
la charité de voilà pourquoi